A little while back, I saw a Reddit post
and linked article both written by
Joshua Wood. It went something like
this. Brackets are a useful tool, but
they have limitations. They do cover
power level to some extent, but they
don't address specific play pattern
preferences, aside from following
general community preferences, such as
limitations on mana denial in lower
brackets. A good solution to this
problem is to have players come to the
table with a basic 10-second pitch for
what their deck is doing. An example of
this might be, "This is my Ganty Cany
Inquisitor rogue deck. It's a theft deck
that wants to hit people with evasive
rogues to steal cards and eventually
pump up my rogues for the win. It's
bracket 3. First thoughts, this is fine.
A very normal opinion to have and a
reasonable suggestion. I already do some
version of this, as do most people I
play with in public. At least half the
time when I'm reading the commander of a
stranger I'm playing against or when I
make a comment about it, they'll drop me
a basic pitch for how they're using the
commander or what their deck is doing.
The only critique I might have of this
idea is that it's maybe a little odd to
have a pitch like this rehearsed word
for word and delivered like some sort of
theatrical monologue, but the broader
point about communication is good. Or so
I thought. This post was not all that
popular on our/EDH. 63 upvotes and 89
comments at the time of recording with
some comments critical of the idea
getting more up votes than the post
itself. Revealing what your deck does by
playing it sounds way more fun to me
than everyone giving a synopsis on how
the game is going to go before it even
starts. You don't need to tell other
players your deck's life story, an
interesting fact about it, or even a
basic strategy. Once everyone chooses
their commanders, and commanders are
revealed, they can deduce strategies
from there. Leaving some mystery to the
game is fun. It means we can play to
figure out each other's weakness instead
of basically being told. In the broader
scheme of things, this doesn't matter. A
modestly visible Reddit post attracted
some people with opinions I disagree
with, who then got a handful of up
votes. Big whoop. However, I can't get
this line of thinking out of my brain.
And these opinions are similar to
comments I've received on my channel in
the past. There seems to be a large
online faction of Commander players who
think this way, who treat Commander as
some sort of detective game where a
large part of the gameplay is figuring
out what's going on in opposing decks,
or alternatively as some sort of show
that you wouldn't want to spoil the
ending of. So, I'm going to take this
Reddit post and its comments as a
jumping off point to talk about that
broad faction, this group of players
that I find fascinating, and I'm going
to see if I can figure out what
motivates their thinking, why they're
like this, and if there's anything to
the vision of Commander they strive
after. As a disclaimer, this video is
more conceptual and social theory
oriented than most of what I make. So,
I'd recommend treating it as some fun
ideas to chew on rather than cold hard
facts to destroy the libs with or
whatever. Though this is sort of a soft
response to the trinket mages video
about me in April, so I guess this can
be cold hard facts to destroy him with.
Part one. EDH players are aimless
goblins wandering through the world
looking for meaning. EDH is typically
played as a casual format, which simply
means that players aren't necessarily
expected to try as hard as they can to
win either in game or during deck
building. This is challenging for people
because in any sort of game setting, a
lot of people will instinctually look
for some sort of goal to optimize
toward. We can see this play out in
something like Dn D. Role- playing games
are even more casual than casual EDH in
a lot of ways, but many players will
still put a lot of effort into making
their characters as powerful as possible
in combat. This is kind of pointless on
a party level since the DM can literally
make combats easier or harder on a whim
to suit the players and even harder in a
way that's targeted to a specific
player. Still, the power level of a
character remains a thing people
optimize because they need some sort of
goal while building out a character
sheet. Something needs to motivate the
decisions being made. The same goes for
EDH. People will create goals in the
deck building process. And one of those
goals will frequently be making a deck
that is good under some set of criteria,
at least if you're not one of the
mythical bracket one gamers. So that
will be a part of deck building. But
what about in games? There are all sorts
of skills tested in a competitive 1v one
magic environment. Turn sequencing,
mastery of a given deck list, assessment
of opposing threats, probabilistic
thinking, playing to outs, and so on. A
1v one magic tournament will stress test
a player's skills in all of these things
to the limit. And in many cases, gains
will be won and lost by the collective
weight of a lot of tiny decisions. As in
deck building, EDH's more casual nature
makes things trickier in the sense that
winning isn't as dominant a goal, and
plays that are sub-optimal in the strict
sense might not necessarily be
considered misplays in the same way they
are in 60 card formats. As a result of
this, a lot of EDH players
subconsciously go looking for something
to replace some of these competitive
skills. And in a format as diverse as
EDH, a very common substitute is
knowledge. A certain and fairly large
subset of EDH players seem almost
obsessed with knowing as many possible
plays their opponents can do as
possible. This is especially true for
players playing at a level with sudden
ways to win, where not being able to
recognize a combo piece or a central
enabler for an opponent's deck can
rapidly lead to a game loss. Whether
it's as an outlet for an underutilized
competitive instinct or as a trauma
response to getting otked one too many
times, being able to shrewdely navigate
the ins and outs of opposing plays and
figure out how threatening a particular
card is within the entire landscape of
the EDH format is a skill that a lot of
players have built up. This is
especially true for commanders. A lot of
commanders have a handful of cards they
pair pretty powerfully with, and having
it locked away in your dome what those
cards might be for a given commander can
give you a leg up in determining the
possibilities for what an opponent might
be doing. And if we assume that most
decks within a given commander will be
somewhat similar, having an encyclopedic
knowledge of commanders and what their
typical decks look like can actually
serve as somewhat of a replacement for
rule zero. I don't even need to have a
conversation with my opponent. All I
need to do is see that TASA pull up and
I'm already squaring up for some Ashnods
Alter BS. So, this is a skill that a lot
of players have put effort into honing,
whether consciously or unconsciously.
And it shouldn't be surprising that a
lot of them want to use this skill. And
for a player who has spent a lot of time
around various Magic cards and is fully
engaged in a game, it's not hard to
imagine this being a lot of fun. I see
my opponent play a Blood Artist effect
and I start looking for possible loops.
Think about what sack outlets and
supporting pieces are in color for my
opponent. I see a Karns Bashion hit the
board and start trying to deduce what
counters are soon to pop into existence.
I see an opponent with two lands
untapped on my turn and I try to figure
out what sorts of disruption they might
be able to put together with red, blue,
and white mana. I would be lying if I
claimed that the description of the
commander format I just laid out doesn't
sound like fun. It's appealing to play a
game like that. So, what's the problem?
Surely there's nothing wrong with people
enjoying the format this way. Part two.
EDH is already an unbelievably
information dense format. Dingus.
Comedic name calling aside, this is my
most basic issue with the Vision of the
Commander format I just presented. I
dedicated a full 20-minute video to this
topic last summer. But here's the short
version. The EDH format has become
effectively the onboarding format of
Paper Magic, the way new players get
into the game, and the way a lot of them
continue to play the game. This is cool
in a lot of ways, and there's one
especially new player friendly element
at the heart of the Commander format. It
doesn't have a meaningful metagame. You
don't have to learn the opposing decks
you might be facing and figure out what
decks can fare well against those. And
more importantly, you won't have to
worry that your deck will be too weak to
face the competition. This is wonderful
for creativity in deck building. 60card
Magic typically relegates creativity or
brewing to players with a relatively
strong grasp of a given format, but
since EDH lacks a metagame or set power
level, players of any skill can innovate
and create something of their own rather
than needing to net deck. This is an
undoubtedly nice feature, but on the
flip side, this lack of a metag game
ironically poses an entirely different
set of challenges onto players that
aren't found in a competitive 1v one
format. You can't learn the four most
common decks you'll be playing because
there are thousands of possible decks
you might find yourself facing. This
might be manageable in a play group with
unchanging decks, but playing out in the
wild with strangers is a whole different
story. Any set of four EDH decks will
likely have more than 200 unique
non-land cards, which is a fair amount
to learn if the decks are unchanging and
an ongoing gauntlet for newer players in
a public setting where each game might
present dozens of new cards. I think
most of us have been in a game among
strangers where it becomes clear that
one or more players are checked out from
what opponents are doing, fatigued by
the process of keeping up with all the
new cardboard that's hitting the table.
So, that's the case I'm trying to
present here. EDH has three times the
opponents and often around 10 times the
number of unique cards in opposing decks
as compared to 1v1 formats. There are
30,000 cards legal in the format now and
thousands of brand new cards entering
the format every year. Each deck tends
to play far more permanence than are
seen in 1v1 formats due to the high life
totals in the multiplayer aspect of
things. And the result is that boards
rapidly clog up with assorted permanence
for players to keep track of. The
information density of EDH is untouched
by any other widely played format. And
that is a feature about it that we need
to keep in mind when we're playing it.
All of this is why I find the knowledge
competition version of casual EDH a
little frustrating and seek to reduce it
as much as possible. And that's as
somebody who is probably better equipped
to threat analyze than at least 80% of
EDH players. It's not that I can't
figure out how potentially game- ending
a sequencing of opposing plays is on the
fly. It's that I don't think that should
necessarily be a constant task expected
of all EDH players. The game of figuring
out what my opponent's deck does is just
not one I think is beneficial to have at
the heart of the EDH format. There are
even plenty of days that I personally
wish to avoid this part of the format to
kick my feet back and focus on resolving
my cascade triggers instead of Sherlock
Holmesing my way to what the white
knuckled power gamer across the table is
packing. But still, with all that said,
I could still see somebody thinking that
I'm throwing out the baby with the bath
water here. Sure, knowing a rough
outline of what opposing decks are doing
might reduce the mental load of the
format and make it more approachable for
all people, but what about the
theatricality of it? What about
surprises and zany moments and
unexpected twists? Part three, the grand
reveal, or how to be terrible at
creating compelling social experiences.
A fairly common mistake that's made
among newer game masters in a role
playing game like Dn D or Pathfinder is
placing too much importance on their own
predetermined plot. and especially
trying to create plot moments that will
generate a notable reaction in players.
This strange hilltop village, it's
actually on the back of a massive
creature. Whoa, dude. Now you're telling
me these past five sessions have all
been playing out in the mind of Jackson
the Frost Dragon during his fight with
this world's real enemy, Lord Xyrox.
What a revelation. This isn't to say
that creating unexpected plot beats is
never a good idea, but it's not a good
thing to dump most of your effort into
as a GM or to make a loadbearing
centerpiece of your campaign, because
it's not really what makes a multiplayer
RPG fun. Most players aren't showing up
to sessions to be recited your
half-baked book idea. They're there for
collaborative storytelling, for
experiencing funky situations outside
the realm of reality, for throwing
around die rolls and getting to play the
fun character they crafted. It might
feel good to imagine your big reveal
getting the same emotional response as
some other big moment that arises
organically, but that's not necessarily
going to happen. At this point, you're
probably asking, "What does this have to
do with EDH, Alex?" Well, a very similar
dynamic takes place there. I dedicated a
whole video to this topic about a year
ago, but the basic idea there was that
there are some inherent and unavoidable
problems with decks that like to win in
some grandiose way. I have a deck that
wins by getting three fiend hunters into
play at the same time to fiend hunt each
other indefinitely and cobble together
an ETB based win from there. I also
brewed a list with the goal of casting
Rogu Rock an arbitrarily large number of
times before Jessaing all three of my
opponents for an also arbitrarily large
amount of damage. These are undoubtedly
flashy as far as windcons go, and they
really play into the showing off side of
EDH, the part of the format that is
driven by the desire to have strangers
ooh and awe at the cool things your deck
is doing. In principle, this is fine,
but in reality, you tend to get the
desired response a lot less than you'd
expect with this kind of deck. EDH is
already full of combo decks that can
pull off cool explosive wins. And even
if your combo deck is a cut above the
rest, it's still putting together a
handful of cards that abruptly end the
game. Effectively, this sort of deck
ends up being more fun to build than it
is to play. It's fun to build and tune a
deck that does something wacky and
unusual, but something being fun to
think about, fun to theorize, fun to
hear described as a concept doesn't
necessarily make it fun in an actual
game. Because that's what EDH is, a
game. It's not a museum of cool card
interactions. It's not a collaborative
art installation. It's not a competition
to see who can do the wackiest thing.
It's a game with players and pieces and
goals. It's not identical to a
conventional board game. Obviously, in
the best of times, I'd argue it can be
much more interesting than your average
medium complexity board game, but it
should be a lot closer to that than it
is to reading off a list of the most
interesting things you can do with
Second Harvest. So, that's my
precautionary note about funky combo
decks. And it also applies to any deck
whose main game plan is a bit of a
one-trick pony, such as a deck that is
built to cascade into a particular
threat every game. Still, I'm guessing
that argument probably isn't all that
persuasive to a lot of people in the
context of pregame conversations. Sure,
a deck that plans to win in some sudden
dramatic way shouldn't be hiding its
game plan, but what about cool plays
that aren't gamewinning? Are you just
asking me to cough up all my deck
secrets for my opponents to see to spill
the beans on my deck's cool intricacies?
If I'm to be totally honest, I don't
quite know how to respond to this sort
of question because to me, it's a clear
indication that the person saying it and
myself are really not on the same page
about the terms of the discussion. So,
let's get on the same page. What is the
purpose of a conversation at or near the
start of a game where players describe
their decks? Two things. One, it's a
rule zero conversation. Anytime you're
mentioning the bracket of your deck, how
it plans to win, and what its most
powerful plays are, you're giving your
opponents the opportunity to decide if
they want to play against that. This is
why I find combo decks that win in some
cool way the most relevant example. Even
if you'd quite like to keep your cool
combo a secret to put on some sort of
dramatic performance for anybody
watching, when you're playing that sort
of deck, you should really be making it
clear to your opponents that that's what
you're doing. This could be as simple as
saying, "I'm playing a deck with a combo
win that frequently happens around turn
seven," which gives your opponents the
tools they need to decide if they want
to be in this game with a moderate speed
combo deck. In contrast to this, a deck
whose cool thing isn't a combo win might
not have this sort of relevant
obligation in the rule zero phase. The
other purpose of a start of game
conversation is getting players
calibrated about what's to come. And I
actually think of this as the more
important purpose. A lot of players will
be okay playing against a somewhat spicy
deck so long as they get some idea of
what to expect and what to watch out
for. With my most powerful deck, my
Francisco Malcolm deck, I'll generally
tell my opponents that my deck is fast
with frequent turn five wins and that it
usually wins with time civ. And with
these two things in their pocket, my
opponents will have a decent idea of
what to watch out for and the tools to
make strategic decisions against my
deck. Likewise, with my Sharon deck,
I'll tell my opponents that my deck is a
control deck built around Astral Slide.
This is an exceptionally short
description of my deck that leaves
dozens of cool interactions unmentioned,
but it communicates the two most
important facts my opponents might want
to know. That my deck will be able to
exert more leverage over the game the
longer it goes, and that flickering
permanence is a central part of my game
plan. Performing this sort of
calibration is a good practice because
EDH is fundamentally a social format and
one where players should be thinking
about their opponent's decks and
strategizing the best way to navigate
around what their opponents are playing.
If players don't have basic information
on their opponent's decks, they're in
the dark, who's the threat now, who
might be the threat later, what on board
currently is threatening. If you're
struggling to make simple decisions
because you lack basic information about
the next present, a whole lot of the
depth and the skill of the EDH format is
stripped out with a lot of luck
replacing it. This also ties in with the
information density of the format. In
his video about me in April, the trinket
mage responded to my arguments about the
complexity of the format with a game
show. He gave me a set of cards played
with a specific commander and asked if I
could tell why the given card was in the
given deck. as an exercise to devote my
full attention to. This was kind of fun.
But the issue here is that a real
commander game would have a bunch of
that sort of exercise, plus threat
assessing between different opponents,
plus playing one's own deck, plus plus
reading a bunch of new cards if you're
not somebody who's already deeply
embedded in the commander format. In the
context of all that extra stuff, having
the slightest leg up by knowing a couple
key elements of opposing decks can
really help in not screwing up critical
threat assessments. All of this brings
me back to the people saying, "What? You
want me to spill my deck's every secret
for you?" If I'm to treat this as an
entirely good faith question, I would
respond like this. Hi people, no, you
don't need to do that. Here's a
flowchart. Is the part of your deck
you're thinking about a powerful windcon
for you? If yes, maybe consider
disclosing that. If not, is the part of
your deck you're thinking about
something you'd describe as your core
game plan in a way that would be helpful
to decision-making for somebody playing
against your deck? If yes, consider
disclosing that. If not, you're good.
We're talking about a 10-second or less
pitch. You obviously don't need to spill
the beans about a cool side strategy
chilling deep in your 99. But you
shouldn't need to hide the main game
plan of your deck or conceal the most
powerful windcon. To put it bluntly, if
giving somebody a synopsis of what your
deck does ruins your experience playing
it, it wasn't all that interesting a
deck to begin with. In all of this, I've
also been dancing around a final group
of players, the people who think
deception is a critical part of the
commander format. This is not generally
a group of players I have a high opinion
of, though to be fair, some of it might
be a sort of trauma response to playing
with Some people in the Reddit
thread that inspired this video
mentioned concealing what their deck is
pregame so opponents don't try to switch
to a deck that counters it, which would
be a fair consideration if you accept
that people treating you like is
something you're okay with in a
commander game. But it shouldn't be.
Commander is a social format, and if
other people take pregame communication
as an opportunity to be an antisocial
bully, that's a problem with them, not a
problem with communication as a concept.
There's also another group of players
who specifically try to trick their
opponents as a strategic play, trying to
sneak through wins, specifically taking
advantage of opponents lacking knowledge
of their deck. This is admittedly a
spectrum. There are lesser versions of
this, like sandbagging plays and playing
the small bean with a late game centered
deck. And while I personally don't
really care for this sort of table
engagement, I understand that it's
naturally going to be part of a
multiplayer social format. But players
doing the more serious versions of this,
downplaying an obviously busted board to
somebody who doesn't know any better,
pretending that a powerful centerpiece
card is just some normal filler, and
otherwise skating by on their opponent's
lack of experience, knowledge, or focus.
This behavior is toxic to any sort of
casual format. And if you need to do
this to win, my natural assumption is
that you're not very good at Magic the
Gathering. Part four. So, is talking to
your opponents good or bad? This video
has been kind of meandering and has
involved various different arguments in
favor of open communication as well as
various arguments against the opposite
sort of table behavior. Despite this,
I'm less single-minded about this than
you might think. And there are some
pretty reasonable arguments for less
table disclosure that I've heard in the
past. One of these is that treating less
experienced players as full-fledged
commander players, as well as not trying
to baby them with lots of extra
treatment is both more respectful and a
better learning environment for a lot of
players. This is an idea I'm sympathetic
to. Different players do well in
different environments, and a situation
where everybody else is playing with the
kitty gloves on might not necessarily be
the ideal one for learning the format
depending on the player. Although, I
think this reasoning can work the other
way as well. When I play a very
impactful card, I'll generally emphasize
it to the table. Often times, saying
something like, I attempt to cast
captivating crew. To me, this is saying
to my opponents, I'm doing something
that of course you all as sensible
players who know my game plan might want
to stop, and I'm respectfully giving you
the opportunity to do so. Same reasoning
of respecting my opponent's capabilities
as players, but in this instance, it
leads to more table communication rather
than less. Regardless of where you go
with this idea, it is important to
remember that different players learn
better under different circumstances,
and we should never assume we have the
one-sizefits-all solution to teaching,
playing with, and showing respect to
other Magic players. A related argument
that I find compelling is that
overemphasizing rule zero as a part of
the game can encourage a mindset of fear
and avoidance in newer players rather
than the curiosity and openness to
experience that arguably makes for a
better experience in Commander. If
players are immediately told to watch
out for stacks, to avoid mana denial, to
fear infect, to not play mill, to
disrespect discard, and to ask for no
goat in their games, suddenly you end up
with a bunch of players who exist in
echo chambers and avoid experiences they
find even slightly uncomfortable. The
trick mage has discussed how newer
players in his games have had relatively
neutral reactions to humility of all
cards, seeming curious about this card
they never seen before, more than
anything else. While I don't think I'd
try this with one of the most oppressive
stacks pieces in the game, the broader
point is an interesting one. Players are
subtly influenced by the ways other
people react to cards. And when they
haven't been taught to hate and fear a
card, they'll be more engaged and more
prepared to problem solve when playing
against it. This is also part of why I
care more about the establishing
expectations part of a pregame
conversation than I care about the rule
zero part. It's valid for players to not
want to play against a particular thing,
but I'd rather play in a landscape where
the list of hard nos for players is a
bit smaller. And an alternative to
keeping something like stacks or combos
out of the game altogether is disclosing
these things up front and allowing
players the time to prepare themselves
for these things rather than getting
blindsided later. As general practices,
your opponents should know about the
most threatening parts of your deck
because that's the part they might want
to strategize against. Your opponents
should know the strongest windcon in
your deck, not just so they can decide
if they want to play against it, but
also so they can decide how they should
be playing against you once the game
starts. These suggestions might feel
frustrating for the people used to
grabbing at every strand of advantage
and playing close to the chest for a
better shot at winning, but I can
promise you they'll make for better
commander games and a healthier
commander ecosystem in the long term.
The final takeaway I want to impart here
is simply that the EDH format being
accessible or good for new players or
for players who play less often or so
on, none of these considerations are
binaries. I will happily admit that much
of the EDH format's information density
is inherent to its basic construction.
The number of players, the deck size,
the higher life totals, all of these
things are factors in producing
overwhelming games for players. The lazy
response to noticing this is to throw in
the towel before you've even begun
thinking about it. EDH is complicated,
so it's pointless to take any steps that
might make it more approachable or more
enjoyable for a wider range of players.
A coward might say, "The issue with this
sort of statement is that the commander
format, along with most other things in
life, is not a binary. It can always be
modulated one way or another. Even if
commander's inherent features mean that
some number of players will struggle
with the information density, there are
still things we as players can do to
decrease the number of players who feel
overwhelmed or fatigued or make the
experience of commander more enjoyable,
even for the players who aren't keeping
up perfectly well. Solutions should be
viewed not based on whether they fix all
problems, but rather whether they solve
more problems than they create. There
are undoubtedly some solutions that
don't pass that test. pushing players to
run simpler and more conventional decks,
pressuring new players to play a
different format instead of Commander,
asking Wizards of the Coast to get
heavily involved in fixing Commander's
information density problem. These are
all things that you could argue might
help, but they leave open the potential
for all sorts of negative side effects.
What isn't loaded with potential
negative side effects is talking to your
opponents. You don't need to share your
deck's life story or list out every card
or any other piece of hyperbole thrown
out by some denisin of the internet. My
video a year ago spent a while going
over suggestions, so I'll keep it brief
and simple here. Treat your opponents
like people you're playing a game with
and give them the information they need
to engage with your deck on a basic
level. If you're worried that 10 seconds
of talking about your deck is going to
ruin its fun surprises, that's probably
a good indicator that the surprises
aren't actually fun and that all you
have on your hands is a gimmick that you
and or everyone you know will be sick of
in approximately 27 seconds. Finally,
it's okay if you enjoy any of the
versions of information limited
commander I've been complaining about in
this video. I even see the appeal of
some aspects of that style. At the end
of the day, the biggest takeaway here
should simply be to keep audience in
mind. What's fun for you isn't
inherently going to be fun for other
people. What you can handle cognitively
isn't inherently going to be handled
well by other people. And what works for
one table might not work for all tables.
Casual EDH is a format inherently built
on compromise and collaboration. and
leaning into that will only lead to
having more fun. Thanks for watching and
thanks to Architect for supporting the
channel. I recently did a deck review on
my second channel and the flexible UI of
Architect was so helpful for both
helping me analyze decks and helping me
display their different elements. A link
to all of my decks is down in the
description. Also, shout out to all of
these people for being cool creators and
lending their vocal talents in this
video. A link to each of their channels
is also in the description. Finally,
thanks to my patrons and YouTube members
for their ongoing support of everything
I do here. All of you are amazing. I had
some extra thoughts about how brackets
interact with rule zero that didn't make
sense to put anywhere in this video, so
I've tossed those in a three-minute
video for supporters. I wanted to get
this bad boy out the door, so that's not
quite finished yet, but keep your eyes
peeled for that. It'll be out in the
next couple days. All right.